so pretend you're this guy and you're in
bed typing in random country names on
google flights
checking the prices because you know
after the pandemic is over you're gonna
travel the world and see and taste
things you've never seen or tasted
before
but then you remember i'm broke if
you've ever been in this situation
then you're not alone throughout most of
my life i always found that no matter
how much money i made per hour in any of
the weird jobs i worked by the end of
the month
i was always broke it's like somebody
had a giant tube connected to my bank
account
and was just siphoning money away
gradually until
by the week before payday i was living
on like ramen and
eggs but i noticed something the reason
i was broke
wasn't because there was some third
party involved
the problem was me and i was succumbing
and falling prey to
the three most common money mistakes
that most people make
and unless you correct these three
things you'll probably end up in that
exact same
situation but if you do correct the
mistakes then you may find that at the
end of the month
you'll just be a little bit you know
your wallet will be a little bit
fatter and your tummy just a little bit
more full i said tummy again i hate that
word
okay mistake number one you're
succumbing to lifestyle inflation
lifestyle inflation is when you start
making more money
and then as a result you start spending
more money you think to yourself
sick i just got a raise i'm making an
extra 300
every month now i can probably afford a
disney plus subscription i can buy those
nike air force ones
and i can hit the pub tonight with jim
and rand lifestyle inflation
in essence comes from the weird fallacy
that
okay rich people have nice things and
since i'm making a little bit more money
and getting a little bit more rich
myself
then i should start buying nice things
like the rich people but in reality
somewhere deep in your subconscious mind
you know that the reason people are rich
is because they have money and when you
spend money you no longer have money but
you probably already know this
i'm not saying anything new so how do we
solve this problem
well first of all it's an awareness
thing we have to be aware of this thing
called the hedonic treadmill the hedonic
treadmill is a metaphor
for the idea that an individual's level
of happiness
tends to return to where it started a
set point
regardless of good fortune or negative
life events the person experiences
so in essence you can go balls to the
wall and spend money on the most
lavish and ridiculous things in life you
know if you got
you get millions and millions and
billions of dollars you'll always be
able to find
things to spend the money on and those
things can be really shiny and really
cool
but the fact of the matter is within a
couple of days a couple of weeks
you're just gonna return to that
baseline happiness so if you want to fix
your lifestyle inflation and your
incessant need to buy things all the
time to make you happy
first be aware of the hedonic treadmill
and the next thing to do
is to fix mistake number two which is
you don't pay yourself first so since
you're super efficient at spending
every little nickel in your bank account
with jim and rand
you need to create a safeguard mechanism
that protects you from doing that
something that has your back even in
your weakest most primal moments
and that is to pay yourself first every
single month
you pay the internet company the phone
plan company
you pay disney you pay apple you're
handing out your hard-earned cash like
it's
like it's a free money day
you're paying all these other people but
you can never get rich if you don't pay
yourself
give yourself some of your own income
why does everyone else have to take it
pretty much everyone regardless of their
financial situation
can afford to live on 90 of their
monthly income
like if you learned next month that
instead of
making three thousand dollars for
instance you'd be making only twenty
seven hundred dollars you'd find a way
to make it work
you'd stop buying lattes you'd like cut
corners on certain things
it happens to a lot of people all the
time they find out they're not going to
be making as much next month or they're
not going to be getting as many shifts
they make it work they survive but get
in the habit of treating your income
like it's a 90 thing 90 you can spend on
whatever
else you want to spend it on but that 10
you give to yourself you put it away and
you save it we can talk about investing
in another video but
if you're not already saving 10 of what
you make as a minimum
your net worth isn't growing and you're
not improving your situation
ever just briefly though if you have
debt which is a lot of you watching
probably
i've been there it's called college one
of the best techniques
that i've heard of is the debt snowball
tactic
which was developed by dave ramsey and
that's basically just the idea of paying
off your smaller
chunks first so your smaller loans maybe
it's a small credit card
then you move up to your bigger credit
card then you move up to your car and
then your student loans
and this kind of goes against the notion
that you have to tackle the debts with
the highest interest rates first
and while that's mathematically true a
lot of people just don't do it you know
they didn't get into debt because they
were smart with math they got into debt
because
they make weak financial decisions based
on impulse and emotion so you need to
get impulse and emotion on your side
it's really motivating to pay off your
small debts first
it gives you momentum and it gets you
stoked to pay off your bigger debts
you can move on to your other debts and
then you can use the interest that you
were spending on the smaller debts to
pay off your bigger debts and you create
this debt snowball where you're just
used to paying off debts all the time
and it's great but you can't do any of
that
if you're just paying the minimum
payments on everything and then
spending the rest of the money
everywhere else take that 10
and use it to improve your situation
okay so mistake number three
is that you're falling for consumer
traps now these can be extremely
insidious
so have you ever been going about your
day you know
you went to work and then you went to
the gym like a good strong boy you know
and then you get home and
you start browsing the computer and
you're on youtube and your favorite tech
reviewer says
the all-new ipad 10 point whatever inch
and
at the end of the video he says now is
the time to buy an ipad
this is a great ipad you know lots of
improvements over the last one you
should go ahead and buy it now
so sure enough you go onto google and
you type in apple ipad
and you add it to your cart and you
think to yourself i actually have like
more than i thought i would and this
ipad's only 300
let's get it done so you add it to your
cart you buy it and you pretend you just
didn't even do anything you walked away
from the computer
trying to pretend that you didn't
actually just buy an ipad you ignore
the negative thoughts and you just focus
on the positive you're like oh that was
a nice thing to do but here's the weird
thing that not very many people notice
about that kind of situation
you went your entire day without even
thinking about an ipad
you know you were just living your life
unaffected by this ipad
totally content without needing an ipad
and had you not watched that youtube
video you'd have had a great night's
sleep
and you would have been 300 richer but
because of how marketing works
all of a sudden when you come across the
ad for the ipad or something promoting
the ipad it becomes the most
important and tempting thing in your
entire world
you have this deep sense of lack about
not having this thing
and buying this thing would really just
put that to rest
that's marketing that's a consumer trap
it's like a bunch of little fruit loops
on a trail leading you to
spending money in my own life the
biggest consumer trap in my entire
existence
is camera equipment and my brain has
this rationalization
that oh i'm a youtuber and i'm really
into video stuff so i gotta stay on top
of the latest tech
but every time i stay in this
consumerist mentality
i produce way less and if i've learned
anything about being a youtuber
is that in order to succeed i need to
produce a lot more than i consume that's
kind of the way it goes
in life if you're constantly on social
media on youtube and you've subscribed
to all these like
equipment reviews or yacht club catalog
whatever it's basically just a consumer
trap it's a gateway
into spending money it's a gateway to
giving away your money to
everyone else other than yourself so the
solution
is to start deleting the traps you know
my favorite camera reviewers
i had to click on youtube and say don't
recommend this kind of [ __ ] to me you
know it's heartbreaking but you got to
eliminate these traps as you
see them in atomic habits by james clear
he talks about how
willpower is kind of for losers in a way
like most people have optimized their
existence and their homes and their
online
life so that they don't have to use
willpower all the time they don't have
to sit there resisting urges
they've just deleted it ahead of time
they've gotten rid of the traps
so that they can just go about their
business undisturbed
without all these companies just kind of
like tugging on you to go spend money
on their stuff so don't succumb to
lifestyle inflation
pay yourself first and then eliminate
these consumer traps
and you'll be so much better off you'll
have so much more extra money lying
around and if you want to learn more
about personal finance without getting
into like
the crazy mind-numbing numbers
talking about roth iras and 401ks and
investments and all of that then i
highly recommend checking out a book
called the richest man in babylon using
today's video sponsor
audible and the richest man in babylon
was the very first personal finance book
that i ever read
and it's written in such easy to
understand terms
and has a sort of an ancient babylonian
vibe to it
takes you on this journey it feels like
you're not even really learning about
finance it's just good storytelling but
you are
and it really sticks with you and i
highly recommend the audible version
specifically because the guy
narrating it his voice is just liquid
gold
and for those of you who don't know
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
ranging from bestsellers to celebrity
memoirs
news business and self-development every
single month audible sends you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice
regardless of price and you also get two
audible originals
and audible members also get access to a
bunch of news digests if you're into
that kind of thing and
guided meditation programs which is also
really cool and one of my favorite
things about audible is that if you
cancel your subscription
at any point you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks
including the audiobooks that you got
for free using their credit system so
it's kind of a no-brainer so to sign up
for your free
30-day trial click the link in the
description below
or text better ideas to 500-500
once again to sign up for your free
30-day trial
click the link in the description below
or text better ideas to 500-500
so this is my first personal finance
video let me know what you guys thought
of it in the description below
do you guys want me to go into more
detail next time or do you like these
more general
easy to understand concepts and if you
did like this video
make sure you actually hit like because
when you hit like the algorithm
blesses me and it shoves my bald head
pumps it into other people's home pages
helping them out
helping them climb out of debt and
secure their financial future
if you're lurking here and this is the
thousandth time you've seen my face and
you haven't hit subscribe yet
make sure you hit subscribe and hit the
bell icon
so that you are notified when i post my
next video
other than that thank you so much for
watching and we'll catch you in the next
[Music]
video
you